what's going on reject nation Greg elder
here Rajan Humphrey The Hobbit has
finally been made I'm kidding the ape
sapiens spin-off has finally been made
I'm kidding none of those things are
happening but you know what is there's a
new red band trailer or the shape of
long water which I've seen the begi by
dioxide of water this room is getting
fantastic reviews at the film festivals
from playing at there's getting like
Best Picture
consideration like when does this come
out I don't know but I like why it's
rated R and it's a red band Guillermo
del Toro style beautiful fantasy films
that get violent crafty insects
fairytale
[Music]
Harry Potter behind here picture
obligation and to report it what is she
saying
suppose for not currently concerned as
the asset the Soviets wanted do you have
it sure I'm getting it back because I
know you see something like coming in or
out of the line
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna be synchronizing our watches
just like this
[Music]
time
[Music]
what you say to me
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
that's not a hell yeah man this is the
this is the del Toro I love right I'm so
glad he went with this instead of
Pacific Rim - it's not like hey it's not
three times the features I think he
handed off Pacific Rim because that he
can hand off Pacific yeah yeah stays
true to the spirit of what that movie
was which is like his Explorer
experimental stuff like that was a big
fan of crimson peak Tigers at peak this
is like yeah the director of Pan's
Labyrinth right here yeah this is maybe
I'm just biased cuz these are the kinds
of movies like I would love to make at
some point not exactly was like I love
it when he does this kind of a thing
when it is not so well I guess because
you know the movie business is so thin
now you can see right through you know
like all the more money the less vision
you know usually I like how they're the
two trailers you've seen complement each
other very well this creature does it
have a name it's called the asset I like
how the two trailers you've seen
complement each other very well the
first trailer capitalizes on Sally
Hawkins and the end the asset the
creature and their bond and it can sound
like deaf girl with this creature and
they communicate with each other and
they're like develop a care or love for
each other yeah and then this trailer
has that but it also really amplifies
the intense experience that it's
probably gonna be with a villainous
character like Michael Shannon yeah
which reminds me more of like a Pan's
Labyrinth kind of film like you got the
creature you got the female character
you got the fairytale vibe and then
there's male villain who wants to screw
everything up yeah well I mean the first
trailer kind of came across to me like
it was focusing in on the lonely and the
lovely and like lonely and lovely and a
little bit dark I know you knew
something foreboding was under this
surface and then this one led with like
tension and rage you know yeah it's all
about how they're doing this like right
under his nose or something and it does
seem like a like a lot of steaks you
know Richard Jenkins is one of those
actors I love seeing Richard Jenkins I
don't mean this as an insult at all he
is the perfect Supporting Actor yeah you
know like in anything he's a supporting
actor in he is perfect as that yeah you
just blend with any genre and he's great
at lifting up the other actors totally
it's like he's always memorable and it's
and for some reason he didn't give like
flashy super sincere really sincere and
Michael Shannon god I love when he goes
all dark intense love dark intent what
she's known for do these intense I've
ever seen him was like in the morning
after the rest of the time I'm just like
he's mister intense it just never stops
getting old to me guy he liked Christoph
Waltz's the bad guy I'm over it
Javier Bardem is a bad guy I'm also very
Michael Shannon because because he has a
variance to me on each of his
performances basically feels like a
different kind of bad guy where's that
Christoph Waltz bad guys just Hans Wanda
intelligent yeah he just has those
qualities like articulate bubbly but
also very sinister Michael Shannon like
always brings a living character and I
like the little touch they have of the
creature going like roaring because then
you start to get a better sense of why
people might view this creature as
something dangerous more than just its
foreign it's an alien it does that it's
a pretty scary thing when you take a B
it's like Beauty and the Beast kind of
tail to me and some noise you know and
another way of how it's kind of like
Pan's Labyrinth this is a period piece
that around a specific type of war is a
Cold War era I think I think I'll just
watch Pan's Labyrinth of his back better
yeah that would be a good double feature
I think it would be because I like yeah
is is in terms of like a dark fairy tale
and something we get so seldom now and
del Toro is the master of that I feel
like he could do with one of the
one of these just like uh yeah this is a
beautiful it's not hampered by anything
and it's just a tail you know yeah and
it looks terrific it looks terrific and
I love the colors too like every scene
like the color palette is very specific
on lighting like the first like nothing
less of a donut or yeah yeah I you know
just goes saying but I said it anyway I
like weird love stories dark fairy tales
a lot they're not at least movie wise I
don't get to watch a lot of that stuff
though yeah like Mulder and Scully are
they gonna get together in x-files
I want to believe that's the thing about
you and I man we just read each other
like that like you know you guys yeah
first look at Hellboy it looks great
doesn't it are you guys excited for the
shape of water hey I got a fun question
for you guys what movie would you want
guillermo del toro to actually adapt
that you think he might actually stick
to ha he's not gonna change but I'll do
the hard no other Justice League dark
room too you can subscribe to the real
rejects thanks for tuning in click that
notification bell followed at John
Humphrey dot John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram check out our patreon
become a patron ejecta de Pape sue is a
lot of fun great content over there